So what's the logic?
Something like,
well,
there's an infinite number of
interpretations of the world.
Okay.
You can't tell which of
those are canonically crap.
Correct.
The basic narrative of human struggle,
his oppressor versus oppressed.
We use category structures to can
constrain that infinite number of
interpretations because the basic
narrative is oppressor versus oppressed.
We choose those narratives that
serve our function as old pressers.
So it's
deeply cynical but credible.
You know,
and you can say if you're not naive that
people are motivated by power and that
our interpretations of the
world can be self serving.
I mean we do want to serve ourselves
after all because otherwise we die and so,
and we are centered in one place and
so we can't see everything and we're
biased.
So,
so there is the probability that the
way that we look in the war at the world
will be tainted by narrow self interest
and maybe even tainted by ingroup
interests beyond narrow
individual self interest.
And we know this is true,
but it's also not all bad.
You know,
like we a good person takes care of his
or her family or does that mean it means
you prefer your family and outsiders?
You we're going to get rid of that.
It's a form of prejudice.
Like it really is like your choice of
sexual partners as a form of prejudice,
right?
I mean maybe it should be
distributed in an egalitarian manner.
Hey,
that would be a lot funnier
if it isn't a possibility.
And like in,
in,
in Huxley's brave new world,
that was the rule you,
you shared yourself with whoever asked
because it was rude not to and you know
what it is actually rude not to.
It's seriously rude.
Now,
is that something you want
to take away from people?
You want that to be distributed
in an egalitarian fashion.
How prejudice star you when you
choose someone to sleep with,
you choose that person
and not everyone else.
It's the ultimate in prejudice.
If Hey,
you say,
well that's not prejudicial.
Oh yes,
it is.
Usually go for the most
attractive partner you can find.
Usually go to for the healthiest partner.
You,
you go for the best person you
can find who can tolerate you.
It's prejudicial in,
in every possible way.
So.